Oh No as we get into it anyways hey guys
thank you all for tuning in we there's
new hero obviously as you found out on
gang squad daily if you watch again
squad daily in overwatch it's named
wrecking ball which is interesting
because everyone thought it was hamon
and it technically like yeah that's what
like that's his official name but or
that's like character name but
officially it's known as wrecking ball
because it's not just hamon it's also
the the mech that he rides around in as
you can see here okay guys now we're
already in the middle of a match yeah oh
my god there's a lot of proximity - okay
how long we're good um should be good
hold on
I seen you double-check something
regardless how are you guys doing hey I
see us that's fine yeah no it's it's an
interesting character so we can show you
all the moves later or he will
demonstrate Joey well here in a second
what oh my god wrecking ball can be
that's hit the ultimate which is it
drops a bunch of proximity mines
well you shoot him right or you smash
them before what are you going to the
world going through that yeah I go into
the well and just swing around no
grappling hook no it doesn't work cuz in
let's go I think once you hit a wall
meeting I want you hold that one okay
yeah so you can see the abilities the
preview on it is actually busted right
now but quad canyons minefield ultimate
drops a bunch of perks immunity wins you
have the grappling hook which is you
know you get momentum you could actually
hold that down that movie for those
piledriver oh sorry now hold that down
as in like you could keep swinging if
you want to yeah that movie saw Joey do
there was the piledriver move which is
like a ground pound
so here's Joey swinging around you know
hanging out
also in ball form that's just like your
mobility right like yeah you can just go
[ __ ] yeah love shifting and then
wrecking ball also has a shield wrecking
ball is designated at oh lordy I'm out
of tank correct yeah use a tank so his
his guns don't do a ton of the
like it takes a while for anyone to die
here also because um another thing that
he has our shield so if you press e he
has a shield that actually uh it gets
you get more health depending on how
many people are around you oh nice so
it's like oh oh boy
it right here and now I have 700 oh yeah
at one point I think just now I saw you
with like 900 yeah that's 900 that might
be the maximum it could be like 50 per
person Oh some people aren't digging the
character does that I think it's awesome
none of players Oh like half people like
left that game also just so you know we
are playing on the PTR public test realm
so obviously it's in testing and we've
had a couple like game crashes already
so don't be shocked if we have some game
crashes we'll get back into the game as
soon as we can
again this is why it's on the test realm
public test realm is so that they can
kind of figure it all out yeah in
addition said there aren't they don't
have like skins or yeah you might
surprise actually
nobody spam that in chat usually it's
like show us the skins dang it
yeah so so all the basic stuff right now
I'm sure as with every new character
that hits the PTR we're guessing a
couple weeks it's usually like a couple
who just three weeks is usually roughly
around the time oh you can go into the
practice range so you can show us
everything oh yeah you guys will do that
so we don't risk like that's a gift
showers King Nintendo you never know we
could Joey also practice training thank
you for that I think it's a cool
character I think one it's good to have
another tank yeah um - I I think the
grappling Oh No Oh see okay saved I
think the grappling hook thing is
hilarious and cool I don't know do you
know how much damage it does cuz like it
does damage if you find any lay into
them right Wow all the way around oh he
said how is it a cool character exactly
uh you're rolling ball for mobility you
get to become a wrecking ball that's
cool the quad cannons are kind of
whatever I think it's mainly the
grappling hook no slash fault are you
still connected okay why can't I see him
in the game King frozen BG are you on PC
and on the public test realm because if
you're not then how much damage that did
they almost never have skins in PTR
that's true
uh I feel like they did it once but I
don't remember who was okay so I took
off two boxes which is why is that
is that supposed to indicate 200 health
I think it's like that might be like 50
I keep dying
you think it's 50 damage 50 with like
the knock back I think okay what about
Piledriver hold on let me swing from
here it's gonna swing oh I'm not sure
how much you started off with though
hey training bots friendly training wat
stuff that hamster watch Oh save it
I don't know cuz I think shooting them
I've been like a hundred or so I think
these guys have 200 yeah I think that's
here so in addition to that he has the
shield so if I have 600 health there's
like a little icon at the bottom left so
I guess depend on how many people are
around you I believe it says create
temporary temporary personal shield
amount increases with more enemies
nearby okay
did they have his gold gun there we go
now I have 900 oh yeah so that gets you
like it wasn't me out there yeah yeah
and like with his mobility and
everything it's like he has good escape
right like or at least decent escape
whereas you know someone like like if
you get the momentum right you can when
does he get added I don't know we we
ventured a guest two to three weeks
because that's roughly the timeframe of
when you see characters go from PTR to
the real deal again only on public test
realm which means it's not on console
it's only on PC you'd have to own the
game to be able to select the public
test realm as a region but yeah you
could try it out if you have PC though
okay and his old is the proximity mines
soul has to change like diva now once he
dies he's he's dead sadly he just get
rekt he take it right yeah he said get
right
top speed I'll turn his voice up a
little bit so let me let me get another
old maybe he'll say it again can you
show what the special is we just you'll
see it in a second
oh that's actually a pretty good call a
triplet the alt is interesting I can see
a lot of Zarya combos oh that's good
I'm gonna shut up here over here come on
do they stay here indefinitely looks
like it oh no oh we can go here does it
damage on every collision in ball mode I
think it's just no it's it's only when
you're uh sped up like that we're
glowing orange yeah so if you hit them
like this you'll just kind of you know
bump into them okay but you could in
theory while you're grappling because
you choose when to let go yeah hit on
multiple times right yeah so if you're
like going like this thing because you
hit spacing now you gotta get that speed
up first
little dog well twofer
Janice Rodriguez thinks this game is
dead I don't think so
it's far from it I think but I will say
there are some of the some of the old
overwatch streamers that have switched
over to fortnight I mean I'm pretty sure
everyone is but you know and as such
perfect segue will be streaming for
tonight at about two o'clock so you know
come back for week 9 challenges with me
and Nick margarita all right
that's a pretty good is there anything
else do you need a test I don't think so
I think that's okay let's go fight some
more Hammond's as is the case on with
every PTR a new hero you know you just
get to fight other hamsters have you
ever had a hamster like in a rolling
ball no but I had I own two guinea pigs
which I remember when we were discussing
nails oh yeah pigs look slightly
differently hamster hamsters are like
they're a lot smaller like they're not
as a long they've got bodies aren't as
long and they also have like the bigger
ears and he's like smaller no I don't
know I don't know the I'm know of were
you able to use his voice animal prison
he has one voice line so actually all
the voice ones come from the MEK right
correct yeah you didn't show ultimate oh
yes we did
both times when he dropped all those
little balls those are proximity mines
and that's the OL yeah there's no like
big flashy thing that like you know
sends them all out at once but it's more
like yeah it's like area-denial right
yeah it's like you guys have to get rid
of this stuff yeah but as far as like
the animation goes when you actually use
your alts it's kind of subtle I think we
are already contesting this point also
everyone's saying he looks like this
character this anime character oh yeah
avatar
where is the PMD any at P&G that one's
not to be great here at GameSpot we like
high production quality such as when I
throw a hamster on the screen you guys
think it's a he looks like this guy
I'll put him next to us what do you
think he looked like Hamtaro to you oh I
should put him next to the bottom
picture that's why I should do here what
do you think Hamtaro
meteor strike Oh Oh
doing fist who's in here I was a somber
illusio or reaper wow they're actually
playing a legit game on the other side
there which game is this row this is um
wrecking ball simulator where you play
as a juror who is in a robot oh yeah out
of here oh that's a lot of shield 500
shield there oh you have an alt to
proximity mines and they died it's okay
they're still there oh yeah double kill
that play the game you triple kill right
there but we failed no play in the game
though oh wow you only lost by one
percent I can't save that highlight I'll
check it later
we got people leaving enjoying the game
that's great try this other thing oh
okay maybe I can do that
there's only so many ways that you can
uh and yeah fine I have a [ __ ]
hamster here oh here's one with both of
them oh what's deviantART I probably
can't use that oh man there's a lot of
Hamtaro though here's the default emo
you can just see them like that let's go
roll out that's actually literally what
he says yeah autobots roll out oh shoot
that's a big picture and that's not a
PNG so I'm gonna go right here I just
ruined our picture picture almost that
this nope
still the wrong thing
it's definitely this right no working
keep clipping having some really close
calls with him and it's kind of strange
online and we need a PNG version of eb-2
because that's not gonna fly his sob
rebuff I'm pts um I did they change her
yet let me see really quick I was a gift
so yeah they gave her yep this is the
debuff somber oh by the way who has
infinite stealth one and so they made
infinite stealth an infinite time on her
translocator but they could kill that
though yeah they can still kill it or no
if they can still wait here and camp you
um cool thing though is if you look at
it and just hit eat wait no or
right-click sorry you can get rid of it
so if you put it down and just go what
was it isn't that a good display right
now yes yeah okay well oh look at the
Frank says don't bring the Autobots into
this s show all right there but it's the
perfect you know feels like a perfect
segue
alright let's see if I can change this
one once I die with silver I'll switch
back oh but I have all these hamster
peonies Hamtaro you got you vichu
alright so by the way yes we know this
isn't wrecking wall somebody was curious
about sombras if she's so she's like a
little bit slower when she stole I think
the speed increase is now 50% of its f
gamespot someone set B Oh same as
symmetric teleport well it depends on
your key bindings I think oh woops
that's not a good place for it all right
back to Haman or back to wrecking ball
yeah infinite stealth WTF you can only
delete the teleporter yeah I think it
was the interact wasn't it a sombre
weary working out a buff sure I would
say it's a buff like giving her infinite
stealth like that
oh my I was gonna say if you're near
them pop that shield but Gary popped it
on ya
Sonia was scared
you don't want in here buddy I'm just
defending this corner right here take
that
so as you saw you have to have the
momentum or you're not gonna do damage
wildstar hamsters so he's not immune to
stun good to know yeah doesn't like it
what did they do to characters select so
they made it all that well that that
changes live where they grouped up all
the offense and defensive characters
into one just damaged category and then
you're telling me about that one thing
to where they have like that recommends
or whatever all the mines though gotta
get in there and then she'll - Joey get
that extra shield later up speed back to
Big O to low and they just laid a bunch
of mines down that looks like that race
from Terra a little bit when in danger
just roll Oh agree sonic go fast
oh come on come on come on take any case
that's so cute yeah thanks I don't know
I don't I don't see they beat you I'm
gonna go up home taro I mean sighs I
just I think it's the ears that's why
cuz you yeah Oh No taro he's kind I mean
uh Hammonds gone we got to get rid of oh
no ok they're looking at one more time
yeah pretty close
oh yeah we got you Daniel telling us to
put the shield up when there's more
enemies around us I think when you first
like instinct would just be to use the
shield because yeah ok like I should use
like when you're when you're backing up
because we're getting shot you're like
ok don't want to use my shield now or
doing a weight on closer look it's like
one of those Disneyland rides oh my god
is the perfect map for it this is so
dumb do you imagine like going into one
of those as the ride and you just swing
around
do you shoot nothing you're not playing
the game right supposed to be swinging
around like all these I think all my
cooldowns up okay I'm gonna go the
opposite way oh you're so dead deer
shield yeah a shield okay
that goes almost said look at scumbag
Joey ruining everyone's fun way anyone's
fun I'm making my own all right do we
have the point oh that's actually pretty
good
so he he got piledriver and then he got
knocked up yeah and then now if you kiss
uppercut see you just piledriver back
down right oh boy was it okay there we
go 1100 health yes a 500 from just
everyone being a that's kind of insane
actually this a matter of time as diva
mains are gonna have some trouble
against this spirit furry he's not
protecting ball marker I'm gonna swing
all the way up there watch I didn't know
the principal from boku no hero Academy
is now overall she's a rat though the
principal is a rat now you're making me
question everything but he's a rat I
suppose the rodent family but bad news
what is all the way out here that makes
sense
protect the corner yes
well Jeffrey Zimmerman is considering
stopping playing overwatch because of
how stupid this new hero is I don't know
man if you want to do that go for it I
think I think this here is cool it's
just like people don't react come on oh
right into it smart well played
1,100 health whoa he had a max of 1100 I
don't okay well I guess you could get
too ugly so could you get to 1,200 if
all six were there oh yeah I mean
nowhere to go
they're everywhere man okay I'm at 900
right now yeah
meet him on the other side Oh watch out
there's mine
later we have shield later there's a lot
of them
oh this is not good okay so you can yeah
you can see it changes depending on how
many characters okay yeah yeah that
little icon in the corner for the shield
that's a good one Daryl Daryl awhile
they see me rollin hey that's a pretty
old song actually for me that was like
10 12 million ear yeah nervous incoming
probably I don't know I don't know if
shield oh well too late for that now
roll away what is the new hero strategy
he needs a better alt I think his alt is
fine because I'm it's very very bright
yeah you have to get rid of it it's work
it's obviously for like objectives and
they'll like lay them all over it I
would assume if you lay it on the right
part of the payload and stuff like that
you could do that but it's it's
definitely for like maps like this where
you're trying to capture the point and
go into the wine thanks for the main
tank blizzard says Lucas I wish it was a
rat instead of a hamster alright sure
it's part of the rodent family right
this junk racktrap counter him I would I
would guess you get stuck by it yeah
so yes do my own meteor strike
odhh about oh I keep forgetting I was
like this is the time he uppercutted
alright I have some mines I'm gonna go
swing out and then maybe lay them down
like I don't hear that yeah Oh like that
oh oh yes pretty mouth yeah yeah spread
its Sombra what do you think you're
doing
going invisible okay you got someone I
must have been the sambar running back
into your mom am I in the old oil left
on the point huh yeah
what is his usefulness I mean the fact
that he can get almost what potentially
200 credits in the year yeah
oh oh yeah yeah the game oh is it the
part when I died like yeah it's right
here
save it Oh cuz you got that proximity
mines yeah you got us something you
killed someone with fur they all just
started dying for the proxy but it's
before the proximity you got a heart on
that what come on where's our promotes
when can I do it one can you do what the
Privia
the endorsement oh alright it gets on
the next one or maybe they haven't
implemented it onto the PTR or yes it is
Hammond by the way everyone because
that's the name of the hero itself is
wrecking ball because it's the mech I
would assume right or just like the
whole package is wrecking ball sure this
is PTR - yes Tony
so like I think the last people were
confused in thinking that Hammond was a
gorilla another one right yeah as part
of the rest of the like the the test
subjects basically yeah well you get a
head like a donkey kong diddy kong
situation true like a smaller monkey I
think that's what some people were
theorizing like a while ago I remember
someone made a like a full like
character sheet like with their concept
of like what Hammond might look like and
like all his abilities I think they gave
him like was it like a pickpocket
ability or something to like steal their
ammo and slow them down or something
that's kind of funny actually Liam
there are no new skins currently in PTR
so no skins right now now I love hamster
says Jason Stewart maybe you'll get one
now and it'll roll around as you play
rolling your desk on the way you'll
before it's like imagine a hamster
carrying the game we sort of did in that
one way it was subject that's why he's
so big
oh yeah Symetra also had her changes in
the last batch Juncker at counter is him
and Farah I'm sure there's plenty of
counters and I guess Reaper a little bit
just because he's big big yeah and he
wants to be up close as well as dactyl
says hello hello is that um man Ryan
yeah okay okay I tell you the story of
what happened at e3 no okay so like I
was at a yard house eating lunch with I
think like Chris and Edie and I see in
the distance I'm like holy crap
someone's got a potato mode shirt that
is so sick I can't believe I saw someone
with a potato mowcher and it has he
walked closer I was like oh it's Ryan
she was my friend
what'd you say or did you say anything I
was like cool potato my shirt but I like
my enthusiasm had waned a little bit
because we kind of know right or you
know so oh my lord oh boy
okay interesting okay there you go
I was like you have full momentum so
it's weird that it didn't connect that
one time that guy's just going for a
ride
these guys are figuring out okay how do
we get on now remember this is not real
life application oh nice
because oh it killed me you realize
there won't be six Hammond's in the game
yeah I mean I'm sorry wrecking balls one
is probably good enough to defend that
or like say on the point yeah but you'll
get range someone's gonna shoot you from
far away right okay you're only eight
hundred life felt like you're gonna get
like way more but here's some extra
shield by the way or all it extends
indefinitely all across the stage that
seems kind of crazy Oh
so dead what the hell am i watching
you're watching wrecking ball man you
know I could play the Miley Cyrus song
if that's what what mmm that was weird
oh yeah I didn't transform yeah like
you're clearly in momentum mode or like
you know gaining momentum but you're
still crawl out dudes you have all you
don't even need to mine right now okay
yeah I feel like the what you did
earlier was better they like swing up
into proximity wires only because I'd
like to place them everywhere
all right guys how are we doing this
this guy again cheek you turn it you
can't fit Wow okay I'm going back to
spawn
I need my health just roll to victory
scare I think we're taking it too so
this could be like what Yuma call it oh
what's that
bleh babe beyblades yeah we be a
beyblading that tricks me every time but
hey at least you cleared out all the
crimes look at the Metro up here
use the grappling book Jesus Ari will
use the grappling book where is the
graph where how do we read about it oh I
see us at least he's cute oh oh he could
pouch over again good idea yeah then
he's gonna piledrive on me dang it it's
the one thing yeah it's definitely a
thing to get used to the the momentum so
it says Bakugan that just makes me think
of my hero I hold on let's see oh it is
apparently bakugan battle brawlers and
obviously one of those playing card
games that like then you see this stuff
I would assume can you see some images
oh yeah they are balls that turn into
something yep mm-hmm
all right there I didn't know what that
was
are you doing here he's lost what oh he
left he smelled danger how do I uh I
ain't buying the interacts key
dang it
Oh today put all the mines on the
payload maybe you can put some on top oh
you're crazy what are the pros and cons
of this hamster I think he's pretty
solid because you can get into the
action because the more people there are
the more you'll get from the shield so
he can get up to like we've seen 1,100
we're thinking potentially 1,200
assuming everyone's there there's our
one again Petey are so bound to happen
it looks like they're uh-oh they're
patching mid mid mid PTR this happens
all the time actually if you're if
you're ever used to playing PCR when I
first comes out they do some rolling
patches
yeah I guess everyone's knee-jerk
reaction to any hit new hero almost is
like Opie needs no no and again this is
such a non real world like wall once it
actually comes at once he actually comes
out like this is not a real world
application yeah so you can't really say
that until you actually see him in play
against a lot of other heroes and just
you know one on each team do you think
you think you'll see you'll see main
play tank just because like just from
seeing him right now he has so much like
just a lot of mobility which is
something that uh like a lot of people
and like competitive play really favor
mm-hmm like that's why that's why Deva
and Winston were like we're always like
number one picks and like a lot of comps
but here yeah I feel like he also has a
high potential just because of the the
swing has a pretty pretty any blurting
to push you back yeah
but just like having like the right
angles and swinging at the right moment
is something that I think people will
very much mmm well like try to get the
hang over like this oh where you going
oh it's just soft definitely coming in
there clearly Joey knows more than me
this game wonder if I can then now what
game momentum I think I'm gonna have to
go back he a 600 health of course you'll
see play lol I don't know I don't know
the full meta of I haven't played over
watching so long
the Genji of tanks I don't know about
that but we're big on a lot of like this
Oh somewhere somewhere Oh whoo that's
good with where they're at up there
aren't up top too bad you can't like use
that like forward it goes forward like a
little bit which is nice
don't mind us just rolling around here
Oh hacks
oh nice - proximity I've got a wish I
kind of wish the proximity was cooler on
really yeah like you don't really know
just that they just kind of pop out
Thank You Google uh thanks for tuning in
he also doesn't or it's maybe I'm just
not hearing it but like the voice line
when you actually use your old is kind
of he says area Janelle boom but like
you said that's so bad against other
wrecking ponds because they just pile a
driver back down I was like don't
landlines are you I was like are you
crazy she's gonna sleep you
it would be funny if you can hook
players and swing them around I need my
shield later I still find a hilarious
just like that's the mobility
where's my team yeah they're all leaving
hamster Mane coming through can you
swing through the teleporter I don't I
would imagine that you could and then
you would like keep the momentum
if you had to compare his place out to
anyone in the games wall aside who would
be I'm talking damage output and
survivability damage output and
survivability oh there you go
sick kind of like a diva in the way I
don't know Arisa lightnings kind of the
kids of ERISA and diva I guess somewhere
in between those two because you have
the like the mobility to get out of like
a situation at a moment but it's like
it's it's entirely skill-based whether
or not you actually latch on latch on
swing away
John fewer says if he ejects he wouldn't
be that original besides what could a
hamster do on his own well I mean my
closest comparison would be like what if
he was like Rocket Raccoon you know it
had like a go something yeah like a like
a big plasma gun or something but then
again it would just be like diva at that
point yeah so she makes sense you chew
through the weapons hello
made it alright so do we have to play
heads up again only some people that
watch that stream or a long time ago we
know that this is good is it hit scan no
it's not you might have that alter
actually is it I think it's just a very
quick projectile which one his regular
weapon I think because what in plain
sight was talking about you might have
to kill this thing
we'll see hamster wars have begun it's
fair I'm gonna exit out hopefully we'll
be able to get back in now another
update there we go I think I might have
hits to hit play before initialize make
sense
I need a tank skinned for this little
gent yeah we'll see what I'm curious
what they'll be there's do you think
that there's God do you think there's a
clear one that you can see him probably
a hamster ball there's got to be right
that seems too easy to not do but I
don't even know what that would look
like maybe he would just be
piloting it so you could see his full
body yeah maybe
oh man why not jetpack kitty who knows
that was the thing right yeah like or
like a concept yeah I think I I know
that they they always talked about ever
since released wanting to get more
animal characters they were like oh how
do you how would you do something else
on four legs it doesn't make any sense
well here you go just give them a mech
timba stags asking what happens when you
hit a player win it while you're
involved does it run them over or knock
them back so assuming you have momentum
right it'll hit them and knock them back
yeah but you need to be going like fast
like sanic fast so you need to have that
like glory oh yeah if you just roll into
them like this so just kind of bump into
them cuz this is just as normal movement
speed yeah so you're vulnerable to in
Ball State I can go like Oh maze hold
the mate counter are okay you fixed it
by shrinking the radius oh this is great
this guy doesn't know what's hitting him
oh you are like barely missing them oh
that's bad skirt the line oh oh they're
gonna have some fun mode with this I
would assume what do you mean oh what
are you just trying to get out of a maze
or something I don't know like you know
someone was just saying like you know
you're gonna probably have some kind of
cool movie event based off him maybe I
don't know because you were telling me
at first they're like oh is that a
Lucille Ball
oh yeah when when they or teen or
something so just get one one wrecking
ball to defend the payload as it's
moving oh crap
see if you get area denied like that
all you gotta do that's actually
interesting with lucio speed buff will
you do damage I still think you need
momentum
oh do it oh you weren't Heine and sad
when the gets killed he just he pops out
of his a his ball this dies oh no I've
never seen that sorry dude oh no it
makes me feel way worse now
oh no there's gonna be a lot of that and
we get to with it
does he have voice lines no the robot
has voice lines but audio here is
squeaks and stuff like that do you think
he's gonna be like bashing where he'll
have squeak lines fine naughty boy oh
okay no poor hamtaro there's the reaper
there you go it's kind of flopping out
of the mech don't call PETA on us let
death deck is playing some unknown game
in our D
you got one crazy is this on the live
server knows on public festro oh they
moved this I don't like that or they
drop the mines there but whatever I
should've did near the hey all the way
oh there you go and push the payloads
okay got one oh you're dead oh no I got
I got Oh mind I'm out here I'm out here
for the team for the time I could get
some air and then do the piledriver how
do you headshot him in the role that's a
good question I don't know if you can
yeah but see the thing is you're not
doing damage yeah or like as the person
rolling you're not able to do damage in
the role other than you know when you
have momentum but if you're just rolling
by you're just getting hit for free so
it's not like there's that much benefit
to be how was a big wrecking ball there
we go nothing to see here
what though always stung me in the air
how dare you as an SI swing from the
chandelier will try can you shoot the
mind yes it takes a little bit well at
least as wrecking ball to kill him
though so I'm not sure how much damage
it does he's not a chipmunk he's a he's
a hamster we're pretty sure they have
sir yeah that's how long it takes
yeah it's like unless you have an area
of effect attack it's not really worth
it to shoot them individually in our
nope my cool down.this okay someone else
is doing it I'll do a few from this one
- hi oh he still has it
oh that's not good
[Laughter]
can't destroy shirts with this Bosch I
mean you could damage it and technically
you could kill it if you like if it was
low enough it only does like what 50
damage is what we said roughly the
ground pound does more I think we said
that that looked more like closer to a
hundred damage yeah HAP's
I just info they're asking us how do we
feel about custom thumbnails going away
from YouTube I didn't even know that was
a thing so really did you did you guys I
annoyed I didn't know about that so I
mean I don't I haven't made a thumbnail
in a long time so I'll have to differ
it's gonna sad I'll go ask the YouTube
people though after this I mean that's
obviously maybe it's for like if unless
you have like an X amount of subscribers
or something oh maybe I mean like I
don't that's interesting dang it it was
during overtime well I'm curious like
because it's like if that's the case
like what is it pick maybe like the MS
like the default is like if you have a
couple then like it picks like they give
you three options yeah it's like no
first ten seconds last ten seconds over
like the right in the middle and anvil
one gaming the Brian Schubert who helps
pretty much manager or YouTube says they
haven't gone away so I guess that's not
news maybe it's not news for us there
look he's posing oh did he have golden
guns why not right no yet no that's why
she's a gold version yeah it's just
these
what does the robot sound like I can't
click it shut down yeah that's basically
it like that
assault why is this here there is no
voice lines or highlight intros right
now or skins a beyblade skin sure or a
Bakugan
if how's it gonna roll if it's a
beyblade Bakugan makes sense it's like
so it's like these Joey apparently like
the are ball and then they turn into
like something else I can imagine make
sense during like the summer games
having like a a ball of something like a
Lucille Ball or all the matches over
okay
there's a robot voice by the way
look at you willingly taking that damage
yo oh wow that was really close
you're getting worried there
oh no that's your money field I find his
a little melee hilarious what is the
difficulty of the new hero I mean I
think there's definitely some there's
going to be some skill involved if
you're able to use the grappling to do
you agent to like knock people off and
stuff like you know you just gotta get
like familiar with the angles and like
the the be inertia in which he swings
like and remember he is a tank so he's
not gonna do like a ton of damage they
can hold his own oh my that was pretty
weak
word 79s not a huge man the robot design
it's kind of generic he's gonna get
skins don't worry he's day one right now
he's okay one ball right now cuz he can
Jeff Martin says he can see a wintertime
skin with a snow ball or Christmas
ornament yeah oh gee this is g-force do
you member that movie it was that it was
that live-action/animated guinea pig
movie oh really
yeah and it was weird because guinea
pigs actually don't they don't use the
ball because they're too big they're too
big they would like some reason why they
like added it in the movie just because
it's you know little rodent animal
that's like a bigger one I guess I
suppose pokeball skin tell Lord Jeff
I'll tell Lord Jeff so any hair as a
hamster I mean it's a hamster in a
rolling mech it's a tank t51 be these
mines those mines are gonna piss me off
Oh Amy says what's next and intelligent
roach a pigeon hey I would enjoy a
pigeon here Oh a pig on begone hero a
pecan lowing a swing for this tyre
definitely a pumpkin skin for Halloween
I mean the possibilities are endless one
your character is just a ball it's true
it's like rocket League there's no skins
currently Green Lanes blue so only on
the public test realm currently it's why
we've experienced a couple crashes also
there's no scans no highlight intros or
emotes right now or like new ones
obviously you know the most likely add
that once it actually goes alive
when can we play it on xbox or a / ps4
we're gonna venture to guess around 2 to
3 weeks it's usually two to three weeks
after PTR that it comes out usually I'm
gonna go from the top rope me Harold new
hero pickle Rick I would love that
oh the best is when we had that cosplay
pickle Rick come in oh yeah that was
really good
see you honor
no worries Greenlee as we we got your
back
a turkey skin have they ever done a
Thanksgiving thing oh wow
you lost momentum that's because this
other guy just on there you go 900 help
help I just chilling Oh take that Anna
Oh none of that Joey oh she got
destroyed hmm I need help
Rost really says so we can have same
times PC get him officially after PTR
yes that's usually how it works I mean
the only difference would be that it
could be out like I don't know half an
hour or you know what I mean like it
it'll be the same day for sure I don't
know if it'll be exactly the same time
though for release
I feel like PC almost always gets it
first yeah timing wise and then slowly
but surely PlayStation Xbox they get the
new characters as well because I think
that's more tied to like updates on
their end or that platform oh no oh no
still good Wow say goodbye to Ryan and
IRISA I don't know I think Ryan Hart
will always be I think the deals are
always still going to be powerful
if you're never gonna be able to get rid
shield honestly like I don't think oh
you got to finish her off she's gonna
yeah there she goes
pushing the pail so have you ever landed
any of the things on the payload I
haven't seen it with the the mind yeah
seems like they just go around it his
gun damage seems abysmal yeah I mean
it's like exactly
it's got 80 rounds divas and arisa's
they're just kind of there they're
mostly there it's like poke yeah I'm
sure it's enough to kill this a fourth
stay which is yeah it's only because
we're we're dealing with where are you
going trying to get out dealing with
tanks that are like they have like 600
health and been some that hitbox is
thick yeah cuz heads pretty small though
that's a lot of speed for a tank I mean
the mobility is great
yeah we need a healer vest eh production
says IRISA can counter him with gold
form and grav yeah
his damage is laughable wall
the swinging does about 50 and that
piledriver does like even more like
maybe a hundred oh yeah it's tickling
that mercy so I mean like that's perhaps
his role you know you want to be
annoying
just like getting there wash things up
you know war heroes get shield you know
Winston is more of an offensive threat
though yeah but in the same sense that
he oh he just rubs yeah those headshots
small hamster head here you go
ha ha well the Mersey live I guess so
now that you put them lines in the right
spots to
it's a Furi Furi diva I want to see this
guy Lucy oh there was someone on illusio
earlier
also we were able to the Sombra stuff is
in this PTR as well oh we got oh those
are head shots that we're doing very
little damage he's gonna yeah he's just
gonna be left man hey we left like four
matches because we disconnected that's
true so you're saying it's not their
fault yeah unless almost they were
getting killed by us and then they won
money on mini diva skin forever
I don't I would well I would almost be
willing to take that bet that I don't
think that would happen but what's his
Ultimates it is proximity mines where he
drops a bunch of proximity ones and
obviously it's good for area-denial
does decent damage I don't think they I
still don't think they'd explode right
away I think it takes it yeah it drops
like a lot of them it's like his hamster
pcs gamespot we ever seen quick
champions I think that John Luke
actually scream quick champions last
week we know is free oh there we go see
we're the levers now yeah we're a bunch
of leavers
I'll try playing a couple more matches
or I call it if it crashes again I can
yeah yeah the shield's for himself right
and then again yes shield is dependent
on at first I thought it was for the
people around him but no it's only for
himself a lot of people saying that he's
like ruckus from paladin's but then
there's some people saying that it's
he's not like him I think it's just the
fact that it's a small thing in a robot
he's like a gnome or a nun there's a
goblin and his robot looks more like a
like an actual mech yeah does he roll
around does he grapple hook no what's
his voice line does he keep talking
about the robot does he take less damage
in ball form I don't think so so here is
his ability listings yeah when he
transforms into a ball you just
increases his movement speed that's when
his health runs out it's not I mean
technically he comes out of the mech
what he's dead he flops onto the floor
he's he doesn't get to recall them yeah
that's the best part
filthy cat that's the best part him
dying on the floor Jesus this guy's a
monster filthy casuals asking check
skins there are no skins unfortunately
this is the only skin we got
unfortunately
well looks like Jeff is on our team
daddy Jeb praise be to daddy Jeff tip
inator nose can do
hashtag they should have a PTR for ps4
and Xbox I mean technically somehow at
least on xbox OG he had a test thing
right yeah I think it's just more
difficult right yeah definitely more
stuff that they you know would happen
I'm gonna defend this area right here
oh this corner oh no no you're not
you're gonna get hacked oh I'm gonna
give Boop didn't hack all sorts of fun
things here or not well if you go back
in you can shield for a bunch
potentially oh yeah do you think you're
gonna save this nope that's a thing if
you could save yourself back can we see
new Sombra we did that earlier it's
basically you're just gonna see like a
long our permanent still stealth until
she decides to I'm sure if you get shot
you get knocked out though yeah yeah
okay but like there's no there's no
longer a timer which is nice
BAM it's actually bad against these guys
I don't know they're not actually most
of them aren't doing the actual drop
good if you could have pushed them both
back yeah I think it's it's the best one
that's on the payload cuz that way you
can just you can grapple the payload and
then continue swinging oh yeah listen
about Sombra she her like stealth walk
or run is as long as you want it to be
there's no timer on it and then what was
the other thing with a translocator
there's no she can route what the heck
locator has a No
either nice see yep
uh-oh I'm out of here
so good way to get rid of those minds is
just scary to you Pam none of them
exploded
what is PTR is the public test realm
where Blizzard can put new heroes like
wrecking ball into the game in a test
environment so that people can try it
and also so they can stress test and
also see like what needs to be adjusted
oh it's re public test region realm same
thing to me
but yeah thank you December's run work
like soldier was there a cool down
between the stealth runs yes the cool
down is still there it's still six
seconds long or I'm not sure how much it
was before but it's six seconds oh
that's bad and the guy although you'll
get a lot of shield if you go in there I
wasn't worth it surprise hours like in
the corner oh my god ashen Jeff why
can you try and use some Sombra I mean
after result so we don't waste the whole
surprise oh no I got one more one more
death no switch over see what's like
wrecking ball looks annoying you have to
kill I mean kind of but if you don't if
you fail there and you don't get
momentum there's no damage coming your
way so you just get free hits oh there's
so many mines in there and nobody wants
to stand here
oh this is not good are we good are we
good are we good I think we're good
you are crazy oh wow you destroyed like
seven what yeah they're all what it
comes up in the corner yeah okay all
right he's classified as a tank checkout
so happens it Reinhardt tries his charts
I'm sure if he latches on that they're
going together all right so as you can
see there's no timer set to her stealth
anymore translocator yep I'm still gonna
wait for you see nothing
oh there you go
welcome to BTR ladies and gentlemen I
had no idea there was a new character
yep surprise yeah they they put out like
two teasers and that was it
they didn't really have any build up
towards it there's our boy wrecking ball
you know and my assumption is it is a
guy right who knows Hammond I guess so
we'll find the game someone nope sweet
yeah I'm going with transparent as a
skin like a hamster ball why I keep
crashing because it's PTR and I'm sure
something something like is happening
probably when there's so many wrecking
balls doing something together is my
guess
that retro nurse says he doesn't really
fit the art style it's it's definitely
something different because this is like
aside from Winston who was like
technically an animal but he's still
like you know human ish he walks on its
hind legs and everything he actually
talks English but speaks English it's
it's nice that they won for something
new inside to add an animal idea second
anymore right
the only thing we wanted this game now
is Miley Cyrus I don't think you want
that let's be your other come on you
guys try the new summer we just did the
Daytona as you reload just walk forward
Oh use the Felda it's like a payload
he's using it to okay go to the opposite
way wasn't worth Oh God don't speed oh
you don't want on this point get off the
point oh you let go yeah
oh don't worry your teammates are doing
it not to you oh look at this it's a
Disneyland ride again
which one wait what I just likened this
to like one of those rides where you
just go into Soraka Thea yeah oh crap
you have shield activate like as my help
was going up they killed me can't get
over the name wrecking ball it should be
Hammond yeah no unlocks at future spider
everything's basic right now it's okay
bad idea
oh he's trying you can just stay there
I'm just gonna shoot you then
oh I still take damage from yeah
unfortunately I mean like it's worth it
to clean it up it's your job as a tank
hamster screaming in pain yeah you
haven't seen him fall out yet though oh
nice
is he gone you know okay heal up
stop overextending well it's fun I'm
just gonna you're not coming into my
house oh it's not getting all the way
over here I can't get cleanly through
the window it's gonna take some practice
he could kill him right
oh no he's a need help mean hamster help
has been hacked that oh it's not your
sama it's the other one yeah that's the
other one we have summer no we don't we
have a Reaper in the Hanzo there must be
some like pro overwatch players in here
or something backseat game and PETA
coming in boys maybe I mean when you see
him fall out of the mech it's kind of
heartbreaking Joey thinks it's the best
part that I think it's hilarious he like
just like flops out and then slowly
disappears he has to be an off tank yeah
I can see that I mean do they still do
three tank meta feel like three tanks is
coming back just with brigita
you know just smashing everything like
getting up close yeah good night
Jukes oh well what do you wanna do
maybe go one more crash I want to see
him fall out please Oh we'll show you
him falling out it's heartbreaking
borderline devastating if you're an
animal lover I don't know it just looks
really stupid and gimmicky lol it's not
what I wanted from this game I mean look
the beauty of overwatch and something I
said a long time ago is look at how many
heroes you have choose the one that you
want to play and enjoy and if you don't
enjoy shooting a hamster ball then enjoy
playing against him not with that that's
what we should be doing we tested the
somber buff already just so you know why
is everyone complaining just because
that's welcome to the internet you know
where you get the ability to complain
there is no middle ground here
we have a talking gorilla and a woman
with fake angel wings I haven't seen the
death animation oh we'll show it to you
like I said I think it's sad cuz look at
how cute he looks and then he just when
he when he perishes he flops out of the
neck and just lays there like he looks
like he's sleeping I just kind of like
he's like oh I'm not calling you a
cougar I think there's just I would say
it's divided I would say I've seen a
little bit more complaining but I've
also seen a lot of this is awesome yeah
so I think if you're close to 50/50
that's all you can ask for I mean
obviously it'd be great if everyone just
loved the character but that's not how
that works I guess anything yeah you
know you have so many characters I don't
think you know but again that's why I
think overwatch is so cool
you you have the heroes that you like to
play that like I have characters that I
don't think I'd ever really play and
Joey plays those characters because he
likes them like that's um camo dragon if
you like DVR back maybe 15-20 minutes we
did somber for like a couple rounds I
believe on to the point like where are
you playing the objective we're trying
to we're trying to have fun oh there's a
found you you know what I'm really
shocked by though is that they did not
do any like World Cup stuff like the
Summer Games or something yeah seems
like a good opportunity 16 health will
he live nope besties own release date um
no idea we're just guessing two to three
weeks hopefully yes usually how how long
it is for the PTR characters get on live
servers at GameSpot can't finish the
single game uh we finished like maybe
like one or two but yeah we've been
having some dropouts
it's PTR it's expected
my guess is there's just something going
on with some moveset thing is causing
this to be good it could just be like a
lot of proximity mines or something
that's causing some of these crashes oh
you got heels
oh and well thank you oh man protect the
Mersey Oh Farah which somebody said was
a counter yeah he's not gonna be able to
do much swinging to get up there
oh that's unfortunate but it was worth
[Music]
al-qaeda thinks he'll probably drunker
skin with his tether being a giant crane
we could also get a spider skin for his
rare skin
well we got a rodents nice nice all
right now mo that would have been
hilarious a bachelor trying to run and
then he just gets right
oh he's tank mode he did
it does kind of remind me of Sonic
though once you kind of get the top
speed you can do this
loon plays yeah does anyone remember
Bakugan he's exactly like that yeah
that's what's a lot of people were
saying earlier I made the I made the
comparison to beyblades but the Bakugan
seems to make more sense because they're
balls that turn into like something get
rid of all these oh my goodness who do
you think would be good to get rid of
these mines
maybe fashion fashion I think someone
with like more Splash Damage would work
Farah maybe oh you got hack chorus just
run straight for her oh wait yeah the
enemies you see he's on the floor yeah
oh you could probably see it here it's
the saddest thing can you see no he
wasn't looking when does he come out on
xbox I don't know we're guessing two to
three weeks but who knows we try to get
you at death animation we have to kill
one for you oh they got a bastion back
there oh you're suppose
I'm come on Joey for the death animation
there he is oh he just flops out and
just goes to sleep oh no no oh he's
still there that's so awkward you're
killing the ghost of a former wrecking
ball oh you're crazy as a Bastion
there's more batches of ham to hard
counter look I swing around here thanks
oh no he's trying to get help
wait did he die no no no the point nice
oh oh he's got a oh he got he got deseed
okay it's going so well I think that's
where I'm gonna call it yeah all right
thanks everyone for tuning in if you
want to play wrecking ball or hamon it's
available on PTR just public test realm
I think it's realm right no it's region
it's probably test region realm like wow
there's something or a while yeah PTR
was okay anyways PC if you own it you
can select the public test region
download the update or install it and
then download the update you can play it
we have no idea about the release date
we're just guessing PI to 3 weeks
usually it's about two weeks that's the
average I think could be longer who
knows what are your thoughts after
playing wrecking ball it's pretty crazy
like I feel like that's it's a character
that's definitely go see time in like
competitive play just because of like
the swing is is all skill based so
you're gonna have to really like figure
out how to use the momentum in like just
you know defend points that way yeah
it'll be crazy to see I'm sure he's
gonna have like more play on certain
maps
yeah um than others but I'm also still
curious to see what his skins look like
and kind of like what they decide to do
with the the emotes and intros you're
gonna have a wrecking ball one for sure
oh yeah we're using swing you know maybe
he like swings and then like it drops
down and then he shows up or something I
don't know something fun but yeah that's
cool we're gonna be back or I'm gonna be
back in an hour for a fortnight's stream
the weekly challenge is
fortnight everyone's favorite game but
yeah thanks you for playing
thanks for having me yeah if you want to
check out any more stuff on overwatch
make sure you stay tuned a game spot of
course you all probably see me and Joey
when the character actually comes out
and then we can play the fun
what skins game like you know and then
you'll play the fun
I'll buy loot boxes and hopefully get
stuffed game so thank you guys all for
tuning in and see you guys later peace